da ich seit fast zwei Jahren kein neues
merchandise rausgebracht habe haben sich
einige Fanpages von mir gedacht Mensch
übernehmen das für dich wir haben
richtig gute Ideen und die schauen wir
uns heute mal gemeinsam an starten wir
mit Idee Nummer 1
das diger ich habe jetzt schon keinen
Bock mehr skipp mal weiter zur Merch IDE
Nummer
2 wie ich
komm boah ich hasse euch so doll Idee
Nummer 3
ist das eine
Interkontinentalrakete wenn ich jetzt
waffenlieferand oder was Laser
Industries gehen mal weiter zur Merch
Idee Nummer
4 ach diger ich hasse euch so doll ne
premium
Hundefutter ich lache zwar aber das ist
eigentlich nur Schmerz Merch Nummer
5 das ist sogar tatsächlich
Merch mal und nicht irgende Rakete oder
Hundefutter ich glaube die ersten vi
merchideen waren einfach so ein bisschen
auf Joke Basis deswegen hoffe ich mal
dass wir jetzt nach dem Shirt gerade so
ein bisschen jetzt auf richtiges
merchandise zählen können deswegen
machen wir weiter mit Nummer
6 Laser Lukas
Eier ihr seid echt nicht mehr zu retten
merchide Nummer
[Musik]
7 ist das zkissen die denken sich halt
auch komm egal welches Produkt wir
nehmen wir machen einfach ein Smiley
draufshop.de Merch ideummer keine Ahnung
ich habe vergessen zu
zählen Laser clean klar und
wischpflegekonzentrat dicker wir machen
direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten es geht doch ein Regenschirm
mit ganz vielen Smileys all over das
finde ich sogar echt eigentlich ganz
cool weil Regenschirm kann man immer
gebrauchen kannst du sogar auch bei
Sonne benutzen merchide Nummer 700
kotgarten Luca zum selber
anpflanzen da kann also die Marke heißt
codgarten aber mit selber anpflanzen
meinen die Lauch war richtig war echt
lustig mach mal weiter mit der nächsten
merchidee vielleicht jetzt auch mal
wirklich Merch also T-Shirts Hoodies etc
gucken wir mal
denn Laser Deo was steht
da Anti
scheißedition ich weiß auch gar nicht
mehr was ich dazu sagen soll ein
Toaster ja nach dem Toaster kommt
selbstverständlich der neue
Hoodie
Advents kalaserend der
ey sag mal wird euch komplett ins Hirn
geschissen von der Kuhherde oder was
nach dem adventsskalernder kommt jetzt
aber natürlich der neue
Hoodie Luca carnevalskostüm wir haben
mein Shirt meine Jacke meine Hose meine
Schuhe dann
meine das ist ja kein sag mal habt ihr
das verstanden mit den Merch Ideen Leute
von machen wir jetzt weiter mit dem
neuen Hoodie ein
Kühlschrank dicker was soll ich als
nächstes rausbringen ein Haus in meinem
Shop oder was nach dem Kühlschrank kommt
aber selbstverständlich der neue
Hoodie
Pampers sag mal habt ihr es gecheckt
Leute nein diger nach den Pampers kommt
natürlich jetzt der neue Hoodie
oh oh das ist sogar in Ordnung also ich
würde natürlich nicht meine schielende
hässliche Fresse da drauf klatschen aber
mit den drei Smileys ist ganz cool ich
hatte damals auch mal ein Fantreffen da
sollte ich eine Mädchen auf ihre
Airforce und smy drauf malen und dadurch
dass ich abgerutscht bin mit meiner Hand
drüber sah das dann sogar ganz cool
aus also ich habe gesagt guck mal voll
cool bin extra abgerutscht aber
eigentlich bin ich abgerutscht ich hatte
dre Tage lang so eine schwarze Hand weil
das so ein permanent Ding war Bobby
also nach dem bobik kommt jetzt aber
selbstverständlich der neue Hoodie
oh das ist gar nicht mal so verkehrt
soll ich Toilettenpapier rausbringen
passen zum
[Musik]
Toilettenpapier oh mein Gott nach dem WC
kommt allerdings selbstverständlich der
neue pudie
Laser Laa Kölsch da übrigens eine ganz
kurze Sache ein Kumpel von mir hat hier
in Köln so eine memeseite die heißt Köln
ist cool und ich habe dem schon voll
häufig gesagt diger bringt doch mal
eigenes Kölsch raus das wäre so wild
aber da hast du direkt Krieg du kommst
ngendwo in die Läden du kommst hier
nirgendwo in die Supermärkte und Kölsch
funktioniert halt nur in Köln also diese
ganze Unternehmen Reisdorf Gaffel früh
Mühlen etc die es hier gibt in Köln die
lassen dich da gar nicht in den Markt
rein deswegen das ist auf jeden Fall
ausgeschlossen wir machen allerdings
weiter mit dem neuen Hoodie ein
T-Shirt my
passion und einfach selfie Sandra also
wir haben sie damals immer nach dem Bild
Angela Merkel
genannt aber ja ich würde es auf jeden
Fall nicht kaufen machen wir nun
allerdings nach dem T-Shirt
selbstverständig weiter mit dem neuen
Hoodie Zahnpasta benutze ich eh nie keep
cm and skip
laged ich hasse euch so doll nach diesem
Hoodie meine Damen und Herren kommen wir
nun allerdings endlich zum neuen Hoodie
der ist es ein verficktes
Laubgebläse nach der Pfanne die euer
Koch Youtuber des Vertrauens
selbstverständlich übermorgen in den
Shop bringen wird kommen nun allerdings
zum neuen Hoodie auf meiner Pizza ist
PL
fixer
ihr seid die größten Söhne die es auf
dem ganzen Planeten gibt einfach mal
alle Skandale hier mit reinbringen vor
allem das mit dieser plastikpizza das
triggert mich bis heute ne das ist halt
ein stinknmaler produktionsfeher das
passiert jeden Tag in jedem Unternehmen
in je in jeder Firma aber bei mir direkt
die Bildzeitung stürzt sich drauf alle
Youtuber machen Videos concrafters
plastikpizza diger da ist eine
Mitarbeiter aus kleiner Becher mit in
die Tomatensoße gefallen die Pizzen
gingen nie in den Handel da ist keinem
was passiert ich krieg Mails mein Sohn
ist fast gestorben wir hten gerne 2 ja
halt Maul Brigitte ein
Löffel da wirst du ja jedes mal wenn du
was isst an meinen hässlichen Content
erinnert Laser Luca jumpsare Halloween
Maske e da habe ich einmal meine
Thumbnails in letzter Zeit so ein
bisschen mehr wie Mr Beast bearbeitet
und alle kommen direkt an oh der ist aus
dem Comic ausgebüt
Schimmelkäse ey wirklich komm wir machen
noch fünf Merch Ideen und danach lasse
ich euch ins Wochenende wie man ein
Volltrottel wird wie ich super ihr seid
echt
[Musik]
sympathisch ein Trecker einfach ein
Trecker ja alles klar morgen kommt dann
wirklich das Haus in den Shop als
nächstes haben wir hier eine schuhmatte
wo steht Schuhe bitte hier abtreten mit
meiner hässlichen Fresse sehr schön
nächste Merch Idee ist
das
das kann ich nicht einblenden ich hasse
euch so doll ne vorletzte merchide für
heute ist das
hier ein T-Shirt wo mein Logo in den
Müll befördert wird und die letzte mer
meine Damen und Herren ordentlich
trmel eine Taschentücher Box mit heleise
perfekt diger ich hasse euch so
doll